most people know the food system is
broken and they also know the Health
Care system is broken food may be the
solution to two of those problems I
don't think meat is bad for you in fact
I think it's a super food almost all of
the data showing that red meat is bad
for you is it's just basically shoddy
research my day-to-day diet and people
think this is totally crazy it's
basically steak eggs every day if you
start seeing you know one or two people
that say Hey I did this and this
happened you're like oh that's kind of
interesting then all of a sudden that
one or two starts turning into thousands
and thousands of people then you have to
start to take notice of that last thing
I want to talk to you about is Bitcoin
there's a uh a crossover between your
meat and Bitcoin what do you think is it
about these two communities that kind of
come together all right guys bang bang
I've got Dr Sean Baker here with me uh I
thought a great place to start would be
most people know the food system is
broken and they also know the Health
Care system is broken but I think you've
really kind of focused on like food
maybe the solution to two of those
problems not just either or how did you
become so interested in food being a
solution given that you have this
medical career where like they're more
focused on Band-Aids maybe than on
actual like first principle Solutions
yeah well I mean just like most people
uh I it was very personal to me you know
when I was like I said I'm in my mid 50s
now sometime early 40s I started to
realize that my health was not going
where I wanted it to and I was looking
at you know what are the possible
solutions as a physician I you know
supposedly know how to take care of
Health but I realize that that we're
ill-equipped to do so with a with a uh
healthcare system that we have and so I
started just playing with different
different sort of nutritional strategies
I was already an athlete I was already
kind of maximized that part of the
equation which I think is an important
part of it but as I you know started to
experiment on myself I found what worked
for me uh which I thought was great
that's great but then I started to have
the audacity to try this out on patients
and and that's where I really saw a
really interesting thing is I started to
shift the patient's nutrition the ones
that would do it not not everybody wants
to do it but the ones that did I started
to see people that I had scheduled for
surgery like people lining up for knee
Replacements you know I had horrible
x-rays horrible pain and we would change
their nutrition and all of a sudden
their pain would go away which I thought
was quite quite shocking even in absence
of weight loss you know people that they
would lose just a few pounds and yet
their knee pain which was you know 9 out
of ten is now minimal to none so we
would end up canceling surgeries for
these people and I you know I I
proceeded to doing that for a couple
years and I realized that there has to
be a better way you know our Health Care
system is so bloated it is you know we
spend way too much money on that and the
results we get are quite frankly awful
so there's a lot of people who I've had
on talk about different diet and food
and all this stuff uh the two people who
I've been most interested I had a heart
surgeon come on and he was like hey
here's the way to not have to have the
heart disease heart surgery all that
stuff uh you as an orthopedic surgeon uh
you've tried this stuff on yourself but
also you have a bunch of data points I
don't know how many surgeries or
patients you've had over the years but a
lot
let's kind of drill into this idea of
the knee surgeries usually what were you
going to operate on and like why did a
change in diet have an impact on the
knee right and pain and kind of all
these aspects I don't think people would
connect what you're eating with maybe
literally knee pain yeah so the way I
was trained and most orthopedic surgeons
today are still taught this it's all
about mechanics biomechanical forces as
we gain weight we you know we magnify
how much load is put through the neutron
and the biomechanics are true so the
assumption is you know you got somebody
who's overweight they're going to have
arthritis as a consequence of them
carrying too much weight and the typical
progression would be you know somebody
come in with knee pain say they're in
their 30s you say well you know maybe
lose a few pounds do some physical
therapy strikes and things maybe you
maybe you hand them some sort of pill a
medication and an inflammatory drug that
goes on for a few years maybe they come
back five years later and none of that's
really helped that much because they
haven't fundamentally changed their
their nutrition and so now they are
maybe they've got an arthritis you do so
you put a little camera underneath you
clean out some of the some of the rough
cartilage torn meniscus uh and then you
know that maybe they'll do two or three
of those maybe they get into their mid
40s or early 50s and now you're you're
injecting them with uh steroid
injections corticosteroids uh there's
injections called uh disco
supplementation where you put in a
lubricant in there and then once that
fails you go on and eventually you
replace your knee and so that's that's a
that's a typical progression and so what
we failed to realize and some of the new
research is showing this is much more is
biologically dependent so our biology
not just our mechanics but our biology
actually has a huge impact on
progression of arthritis and so we have
these uh so-called inflammatory
cytokines which are released inside the
joint and they damaged and they
basically damaged The Joint they destroy
the cartilage if that continues over
time we end up with arthritis it's one
of the reasons you know you you know the
question for me was always why do people
get arthritis in their fingers why would
why would being over weight affect your
fingers why would you get arthritis or
your neck you know it's not like people
are gaining a lot of weight in their
head I mean some people call them fat
heads but realistically there's not
you're not really changing that I mean
most of the weight we see is across the
weight-bearing joints but the
non-weight-bearing joints also would
develop arthritis and the reason for
this is biology and so we have these
like I said these Cascades of
inflammatory cytokines we know for
instance uh there was a study I think in
2019 or 2018 or a blank on the exact
year but they looked at insulin levels
High insulin levels were correlated with
inflammatory cytokines and so as we
start to get to diets that start to
lower overall exposure to insulin
insulin is not bad in itself we have to
have some a type 1 diabetic who has no
insulin insulin will die right so
insulin has to be there but when we
start seeing these excessive levels we
start to see that affects these
inflammatory cytokines which speed up
the arthritic process and that causes
pain and so we're seeing you know that's
one mechanism there's multiple going on
here but one mechanism I see is when I
get people change their nutrition to
apply point where they lower their
exposure to hyperinsulinemia and bring
down to a more normal level their knee
pain goes away to a point where like I
said I was canceling surgeries which I
thought was great uh the Healthcare
System doesn't think it's that great
because that's not their business model
their business model is throughput more
and more sick people the more problems
we have the more money we make which you
know at the end of the day that's what
businesses want
unfortunately you and I and everybody we
love and our loved ones are in the
middle of that and we're you know it's
it's more beneficial for for people to
be sick at least as far as a healthcare
model goes
if I was to take all the food in the
world and I was going to draw a line in
terms of food that would potentially
bring down knee pain versus food that
would uh inflame or activate more knee
pain where do you draw that line is it
just as simple as meeting and everything
else or is there well I mean you
certainly can draw the line there and as
you probably know I I'm an advocate of a
meat-based diet but I think you start
with the ultra processed food you know
everything all the packaged carbs all
the stuff that we didn't need 100 years
ago all that stuff is contributing to
disease of various types you know it's
the thickeners the preservatives the
emulsifiers the stabilizers the
flavoring The Preserve you know all the
artificial colors all the foods that
have all that stuff in there we think
they're they're probably causing
problems so if you can just go to a
whole food diet whether it's
he almost hesitates this but Whole Food
plant-based diet or whole food diet of
some sort you're generally going to see
significant Improvement now the problem
is that stuff tastes pretty damn good
you know it's tough I mean you've got
this stuff everywhere it's ubiquitous
it's cheap it tastes good we're
constantly told to reward ourselves
treat ourselves you know why not you
know your life is tough why not have it
why not have a donut that's the sort of
society we live in this point and so
it's really challenging to say I'm just
going to eat you know uh you know just
pure carrots and and lettuce and you
know some of these things that people
will talk about and so people struggle
with that they really do now my Approach
is I don't think meat is bad for you I
think I think in fact I think it's a
super food and you know a recent studies
out of Washington University just came
out like two weeks ago saying that
almost all of the data showing that red
meat is bad for is is just basically
shoddy research and why did they say
it's shoddy research because this is
interesting in that like a lot of people
will point to previous studies and say
meat is bad you what is the thought
process well the problem with that is
most of it is what we call epidemiologic
studies where they just take a large
population they ask them hey what did
you guys eat for the last 10 years and
nobody really knows I mean nobody really
keeps accurate records so at best just
to guess so you've got really poor data
coming in at the beginning and then it's
horribly confounded so it's like well
what else were you eating with that meat
were you eating fast food at McDonald's
is it shakes and fries and you know and
you know seed oil or you know French
fries cooked in soybean oil uh is it are
there other factors that go on with this
you know we see meat eaters have high
rates of auto accidents why would that
be why would that make sense it's just a
con it's just a confounder that we know
these people tend to engage in less
healthy Behavior so if you get someone
like me who takes care of himself
exercises regularly you know doesn't you
know sleep gets good sleep and we can
talk about all these other factors and
happens to eat a lot of meat my health
is generally pretty good in fact my
health is generally better than by far
the average American and so uh so the
research you know again has been that
over and over again and the problem is
the researchers say well that's that's
the best we can do because we can't do
an ethical study we can't do a you know
20 30 year study just feeding people
this and randomizing them you know it's
just it's just technically you know
impractical to do and it costs too much
money so they're saying like well that's
the best we have so we have to deal with
the data and we just you know we'll look
where the the trends lie and to me it's
like you know if you were to get on a
plane here at you know Miami
International Airport and you kind of
got in there and you looked and the door
was wouldn't shut all the way and you
looked in the cockpit and one of the
pilots was drunk and you know one of the
landing gear is broken and one of the
Wings is kind of wobble you're like I'm
not getting on that there's no way but
but this is what we accept for
nutritional uh um science and so it's
really bad science in general it's just
not a hard science you can't take all
your your subjects and you know
sacrifice them and cut them open and see
what happens that's just not what you
can do with humans because it's
unethical to do so so we've got this
huge huge you know 50 60 70 years of
nutritional information which largely is
just not very good science how much of
that is ignorance and like just like bad
science best we have type uh argument
versus there's malice whereas right
companies saying hey we know what we're
pushing we understand we've engineered
the food to be more addictive and like
that's actually the problem not so much
just like hey scientists are doing the
best they can I think there's yeah I
think certainly both of those things
exist I think there's people that's
trying to do the best they can just like
most Physicians are trying to do the
best they can but they're in a limited
system but you would have to be
incredibly naive to not realize that
there is a lot of financial interest in
what goes into these studies and a lot
of a lot of these companies like for
instance uh there was this company
called Beyond me who makes this you know
I like to call it human pet food burger
right it's it's ground up pea protein
and canola oil and 57 other ingredients
or something like that and so they've
partnered with the American Cancer
Society to show that their burgers uh
are going to lessen rates of cancer now
they're basically paying for that out
outcome I mean and we know that we know
that when corporations pay for studies
about 90 percent of the time or 85
percent of the time the outcome agrees
with whoever's funding them so they know
they can they can they can pay for the
science and they can they can measure
what they want to measure and they can
spin it you know of course we have the
media that's being you know also paid
for it to spin the story the way they
want to so a lot of it is manufactured
and the problem I mean the nice thing
around Health you know when people tell
me like the climate is getting warmer I
have really no way to personally verify
that I can't go outside and say wow it's
hot today it must be or it was cold
today it must not be I can't I can't
confirm that what I can do is I can look
at the mirror and say am I healthier am
I less healthy I mean that's pretty easy
for all of us can verify that so
whatever you're doing intervention-wise
you should be able to know that my
energy is better my joints don't hurt as
much I sleep better my mood is better my
libido is better my body composition is
better that's something you can
independently verify so this is the nice
thing about that they can you know it's
hard to Gaslight people into into you
know although they're trying dying you
know they're trying to try to normalize
obesity and say oh it's healthy and
everybody should be this way and we're
promoting that there and the problem
with that is we're accommodating that
we're normalizing it and we're creating
more of it and and those people guess
what guess guess who makes a lot of
money on those people when everybody's
sick and overweight they require more
medication they require more services
companies that benefit that are you know
those are the recipients of that when
you started to experiment on yourself
because I think that's a really good
point of like their studies and people
can read them and some people agree with
them some people disagree with them
their studies that contradict each other
whatever but like you do know whether
you feel better or you feel worse you do
know whether your own vitals are getting
better or worse
you said that you experimented with a
bunch of different things you were
trying to figure out your specific
solution was that like uh the scientific
method where you like were very
regimented and like actually running
experiments or was it more so like hey
I'm gonna try to eat this way okay I
don't feel so much better let me try a
different way and it's more kind of uh
uh lackadaisical but you eventually came
to the conclusion that meat was a was a
key component yeah I mean kind of a
little of both and so I'm an athlete and
I've competed at a number of sports and
I'm very sort of meticulous when I
compete and I know what I'm doing better
it's objective performance and so in the
beginning it was like Hey I'm you know
I'm 42 years old I have sleep apnea my
blood pressure's getting up there I'm
probably pre-diabetic I'm heavy than I
want to be those things either get
better they get worse and so I noticed
that you know first of all just cutting
my calories dramatically and exercising
that did work that's what we hear a lot
of people so just eat less exercise more
that's been the Mantra forever that did
work however for me it wasn't
sustainable because I was I mean I was
literally I was practicing surgery I was
getting up at four or five o'clock in
the morning jump rope three thousand
times you you know on my lunch hour I'd
go get a workout and then before I go to
I get home put my kids to sleep jump
rope another couple three thousand times
I did that I dropped 50 pounds at a
period and about three three months got
a lean I went from 290 down to about 235
and I was lean and I was miserable I
mean all the nurses at the hospital said
hey Dr Baker We like the fat doctor bike
Baker a lot better than you are now so
it's kind of becoming an ass you know I
was just like grouchy and hungry all the
time wow so then I you know then I just
kind of experiment with different diets
I said I can't do this I can't do this
low-fat you know mostly size and lean
meat all the time it's just it's just
not I don't enjoy it and so I experiment
with all these different things
eventually ended up on this crazy you
know eating you know basically all meat
and did you try to become a vegetarian
at all I never no I never I was never I
was never that brain damaged enough to
do that
no I I uh I you know I was I was eating
a lot of vegetables and lean meats and
stuff like a lot of fiber and I did that
but I just was like I can't give it up
I'm just you know I didn't I'll be truth
be told I never really liked vegetables
that much anyway even as a kid I never
liked them I just I still don't know
which which works out well for me but as
I you know as I got towards you know as
I'm getting closer and closer to 50 I'm
starting you still compete as an athlete
and I started taking this competitive
rowing Sports concept 2 machine CrossFit
runs on the US you know the Olympic
rollers have these competitions on there
you can kind of see what your physiology
is doing so I got on there and I was
able to set several American records on
that and then then I switched over to
this fully carnivorous diet and I
literally blew all the records I had
already set out of the water so you hold
on a second you're uh nonchalantly
mentioning this but you at uh almost 50
years old showed up to a basically a
brand new sport that you'd never
competed in before and you started to
break the American records for them uh
was it age specific or this is American
records overall yeah so when I was 40 39
I broke the 40 plus age record which was
about a second or two slower than the 20
plus I was pretty much competing like I
I routinely over the distance I was
competing could be could beat Olympic
athletes in their 20s over those
distances and I still can even at 56. uh
so but when I turned 50 about six months
after switching to this Omni Diet I
fully increased my performance I I
looked at the power iPad by eight
percent which is significant when you
already have the American record you you
increased by eight percent that's a big
performance difference and I noticed a
lot of other things I like my I had
chronic tendonitis in my right knee that
had bothered me for about a decade as an
orthopedic surgeon I know all the tricks
that you're supposed to do
therapeutically and none of it really
worked I just I just kind of resigned
myself that I'm gonna live the rest of
my life with this knee pain and I'm
getting older and slowing down and you
know the stuff that we all tend to tend
to accept and literally within two
months it was like it was gone and it
just disappeared it was gone it's been
gone for six years now so when you
switch to the all meat diet is it
literally all meat or is it like all
meat plus uh some vegetables or like how
do you think about like what you eat
right so my day-to-day diet and people
think this is totally crazy it's
basically steak and eggs every day all
day every day three four pounds of steak
a day 12 18 eggs a day something like
that depending on how big I want to be
at the time like right now I'm kind of
bulking up a little bit I'm close to
260. but um
so that's pretty much what it's been
more or less for six years I've gone
periods of two years right nothing but
red meat nothing I mean steaks every day
I gotta I probably cook
six or seven thousand stakes in the last
six five six years I'm not kidding I'm
not exaggerated this I mean every day
two or three are you good at cooking
them by now I'm good at cooking them
right I've got it down a little bit of
practice I've had a lot of practice I've
fortunately not ruined too many steaks
but uh I mean sometimes you know like
I'll sometimes I'll throw a little dairy
in there I'll be off some seafood in
there from sometimes sometimes I'll eat
chicken fish uh things like that every
once in a while I'll have like for
instance we we we're here visiting
Florida we went down to the Florida Keys
I had to buy the key lime pie because I
was like okay I'm in Key West I want to
try a piece it was just one bite just
one bite it was Kermit's kermits
something like that have you ever been
down there it's supposed to be a good
one so I mean so I you know every once
in a while I'll go off off track but I
mean generally 98 99 of the time I'm I'm
pretty a pretty stick to this and the
reason is not because I believe in it or
anything I just feel better that way so
it's like I like feeling better you know
after a certain point you're like I
could eat that and I'll taste good for
like three minutes but then I'll feel
like garbage for you know the next six
hours or the next day or two is worth it
to me and at this point in my life it's
really not I I have a lot of fun
just living and doing stuff and being
able to to to to enjoy life I don't get
my entertainment from from what I put on
my plate yeah
um what about during the day are you
eating three times a day five times a
day one time a day like
if you're just eating mostly meat or
meat and eggs how many times a day so
this is the interesting thing about this
diet you know like I said I don't care
what people eat I'm happy for anybody if
they can find something that makes them
healthy good for them the unique thing
about this is it's extremely satiating
and so there's this concept of cessation
and satiety satiety is how long you can
go between meals like if I eat a big old
meal if I if I sit down in any you know
two pounds of Ribeyes steak and six eggs
I'm good for eight ten hours I don't
have to eat again right and you know
again I'm also a big person so that's a
lot of food it sounds like but say for
the average person they go to the you
know they eat a ground a pound of
hamburger four eggs they're usually good
for about eight ten hours and so you
have this long period of satiety but
also you have this satiation where you
eat enough and you're like I'm good I
don't need anything else so typically my
pattern has been and and that's been a
pattern of the tens of thousands of
people that I've now seen do this it's
about twice a day for most people some
people can do one meal a day some people
eat more frequently but I mean it's
honestly you just don't need it you're
just not hungry you know I had I had uh
two ribeye steaks for breakfast and I'm
good until till dinner tonight so I'm I
don't feel any I don't think about food
I'm not always obsessing about it I'm
not shopping all the time planning so
it's convenient but the other thing is
because it drives Cravings away so well
for so many people we have so many
people we mentioned this problem
everybody's addicted to all this
processed garbage it's everywhere and so
it's tough to overcome that with you
know you can go on a diet you know
you're on a diet you can feel it because
you're just you're you're sacrificing
your you I'm just going to be good and
then on the weekend I'm gonna go I'm
gonna blow it out or whatever but with
this I mean ask me about one of my cheat
meals I'm like I eat a freaking ribeye
steak every day I have a cheat meal
every single day every meal is a cheat
meal for me so I don't feel like I'm I'm
sacrificing nor do most people that do
this over over the time of a long period
it's interesting you eat in the morning
you eat at night there's a lot of people
who do
intermittent fasting and those types of
diets and they'll try to pack a bunch of
food into a very short window of time uh
any Credence to uh the intermittent
fasting stuff or is it you actually look
at like the 10 12 hours that you're not
eating as part of you know that type of
diet yeah well I mean certainly I mean
there is some benefit to to a fasting
window or or you know feeding window and
I think certainly some of the Circadian
bodies like biology would point to that
now ultimately most people will argue
that that basically cuts down the amount
of time you can eat so then you eat less
and I think there's pretty good
literature support that you know but
it's a convenient way to restrict
calories now what I find particularly is
that my sleep is better if I don't eat
late so if I'm eating at eight nine PM
I'm gonna have a less restful night of
sleep than if I eat earlier in the day
so I think there is and I think the
Circadian biology studies seem to
support that I think part of it has to
do with protein metabolism if you're
eating a big huge bolus of protein
before you get to bed your body has to
deal with that nitrogen and so usually
what happens is you end up having to go
pee you know you have to go you know to
urinate in the middle of the night and
then you get up at three o'clock in the
morning and do it then you just don't
sleep as well so I try to like I'm on
vacation now but at home when I'm when I
have more control or whatever I'll
usually have my last meal usually before
5 p.m oh interesting so you try to eat
before 5 p.m somewhere in that time
frame yeah when you begin the all meat
diet did you measure blood did you kind
of uh track the changes to your body or
was it just going off your intuition and
kind of how you felt well you know
that's a good question because when I
was on so when I was on Joe Rogan's
podcast several years ago and I said
what labs and I said Joe I'm not sure
what labs are are going to tell me the
most information I still have that sort
of thought I mean I think the things
that we really want to pay attention to
are what's actually going on with regard
to disease and so can we look at our
blood vessels can we look at our heart
can we look at our Body Concepts can we
look at our performance to these to me
those things are more indicative of
what's going on chronically with health
now I can check my blood cholesterol
today and I can check it tomorrow I'm
going to get a different number so which
number is the right number I don't know
and they can they can they can vary
quite dramatically you know you can look
at your your blood glucose is varying
every five minutes quite honestly if
you're wearing a CGM you'll see it can
go up and down uh so what number is the
right number and so I I I think these
Labs can be useful and helpful and you
know some people use them as risk factor
particularly lipids but at the end of
the day it's like you know what is your
what is going on with your body
composition what is going on with your
blood pressure if you look at your
arteries and I've had a heart scan where
I've looked at my arteries perfectly
cleaned zero evidence of any
calcification which again generally I
mean there's there's a lot of things
there are a lot of ways to assess
cardiac risk but this is generally
accepted as very very low cardiovascular
risk which is a major concern with red
meat and heart disease now again we just
talked about this new study that came
out that said all that's bunk anyway and
and this is what I'm saying you know I
get a lot of people that are clearly
sick and we'll talk about autoimmune
juice because I guess uniquely
interesting you know they're overweight
they're diabetic they have high blood
pressure they don't feel good and they
go on an all-meat diet and all that
stuff gets better I mean they're
literally blood pressure normalizes or
their diabetes goes away they lose all
this weight they get leaner they they
put on muscle their libido goes through
the roof
that to me is indicative of getting
healthier I don't care what anyone else
decides to say about this or that lab
marker you know we really want to assess
is how we're feeling and if you ask
people what they care about you know
like do I really care if my audio
cholesterol is 97 or 116 does it really
matter to me or do I care about I don't
have depression every day that I don't
hurt all the time and I think those
things are what we should be we should
really be focusing on so
if you had a patient company you say hey
I'm going to try this or is there a
protocol of what you would say is like
okay write down how you feel uh go get a
lab go get your blood pressure taken
like what would you tell them as to kind
of put a snapshot in time and then how
often would you have them look at that
yeah so that's a good that's a great
question and so I'll mention you know we
have a company Rivera Health which that
is exactly what we'll be doing I mean
not everybody will go on a car and we're
not for those that will need it I think
certain autoimmune diseases certain gut
issues and things like that but at the
end of the day
um what we want to do is you know first
of all you have to know who you're
dealing with so if you've got a patience
on a lot of medications
you've got to be a little bit careful
with that because if you take a diabetic
and you take them off a significant
amount of carbohydrates
their blood glucose May bottom out
unless you taper down their diabetic
meds particularly things like insulin
same thing with with blood pressure
somebody's got really high blood
pressure and they're on all these meds
and all of a sudden you take away that
inflammatory component now they've got
hypotension and they're you know at risk
of falling down passing out things like
that so we have to know who you're
dealing with
um I you know as I've done this sort of
in the non-medical space for years just
telling people about you know how to
deal with diet most people you have to
deal with some level of addictive
behavior there's always a psychological
aspect and so I I tell people at the
beginning just eat enough to stay to
stay full to stay content and and you
know if you do that over a long enough
period of time then all of a sudden
those other trigger foods whatever they
might be chocolate cake or candy or
potato chips or pizza or whatever it
might be that you're that you really
really like to eat all of a sudden
becomes less appealing to you and you
don't really need that and at that point
and that's usually somewhere two three
months in then you're able to start
let's start tapering things you know
maybe you can maybe you can just how
much you when you eat the fact the
protein ratios things like that and then
and then that usually you know steads
them on for quite a while but we see
that you know we collected data on about
12 000 people doing the diet but the
three month point was when we saw a big
inflection point for for when these
diseases started to resolve pretty
consistently some people within days I
mean literally within two or three days
their blood glucose will normalize like
particularly these diabetics uh so it
really depends on who you're dealing so
there is some degree of personalization
so I can't just say everybody do this
because you know some people you're
gonna you're gonna have problems with
that what about on the stakes themselves
one of the things I see people do is
they'll they have eaten healthy and
they'll go and they'll get something
that's supposed to be healthy and then
they put a bunch of [ __ ] on it right
and all of a sudden it's not healthy
because of all the uh additives all of
the sauces all that type of stuff do you
just eat
steak that you've cooked with nothing on
it uh how do you cook it what do you
kind of do to ensure that you're
actually getting as many nutrients as
possible and not screwing up the
quote-unquote healthy food yeah so I
mean you know I guess you know if you go
to the grocery store and you've got this
pre-packaged you know meat dish which
comes in soybean oil and wheat gluten
and barbecue sauce with 75 grams of
sugar yeah you're probably you're
probably diminishing the overall
healthfulness of that again staying with
Whole Foods that single ingredient Foods
is always a good answer for me I mean
I've gotten to where you know in the
beginning and I tell people in the
beginning hey if you need some seasoning
on there go for it you know it's going
to help you to transition over but most
people myself included over a period of
time we really get to where we really
appreciate the flavor of a good cut of
meat you know you get a really high-end
quality steak it shouldn't need much you
know you know a lot of these sauces and
Seasonings because you're eating you
know low quality food or food that needs
that to taste palatable a really well
you know well marbled steak a little bit
of salt a little bit of fire and that's
basically all I need and I'm a happy man
you know uh you mentioned salt and uh
how do you think about salt intake how
do you think about uh making sure you
have enough or or uh what do you just
kind of do there well you know we've
seen a lot of literature that says
sodium has a problem you know salt is a
problem in society well I think the real
issue with that is because it's really
salty food and what is salty food it's
all this process of potato chips
pretzels you know biscuits you know
breads you know things like that they
all come with a lot of salt in there so
when we cut all that out of our diet our
sodium intake dramatically drops I still
think we tend to need some or many
people do meat has some sodium and it
has some potassium in it but I tend to I
think this is a simple feedback mess and
it's salt to taste you know you what
tastes good to you and there's a reason
why it tastes good to you when you over
salt something you clearly know it's
like oh my God I can't eat that it's too
salty that is your body's way of
regulating your sodium your body does a
very good job of protecting that you
know for if we've got intact kidneys and
an intact functioning you know metabolic
system then it's pretty well regulated
but most people just salting to taste as
all you need to do now if you're living
you know if you're exercising a lot like
I I'm you know I do a lot of exercise
I'm sweating a lot I sometimes have to
add a little bit to that so I'll take an
electrolyte drink or just increase my
salt intake a little bit for that yeah
what about liquids like water uh
Gatorades electrolyte drinks yeah I mean
I'm pretty much mostly just water I mean
I'll I'll uh you know sometimes I'll add
an electrolyte powder to that but uh you
know every other animal on the planet
drinks water right I mean that's that's
what they do and that's that's what
we're supposed to drink so water works
pretty well
um I you know as far as like Dairy and
things like that I tend to stay away
from drinking calories in general just
because I think one of this is one of
the problems one of the reasons we have
such a problem with obesity is that it's
you know like like I I won't knock on
Gatorade there it's a Gatorade zero so
not so bad but you know if you're
drinking pure sugar like the soft drinks
we know are awful for us I don't think
anybody out there would say that
sufferings aren't a problem it's liquid
calories it's very easy for us to
assimilate that but the same thing with
these powders you know one of the things
if you and I were to run around in the
wild you know I don't know maybe not on
the beach here but let's say we're out
we're out in the woods in North Carolina
right we're gonna go we're gonna go
looking for food we may find some you
know some squirrels or whatever we might
find a deer or something like that we
may be nice to find some berries well
we're not going to find our powders
we're not going to find flour We're not
gonna find Refined Sugar We're not gonna
find protein powder we're not going to
find Gatorades we're not going to find
even butter so all these
um highly processed refined
um highly increased surface area of
foods that's not what our digestive
system is designed to do so when we
challenge it with that we get all these
gut problems we get these uh weird uh
you know uh so our gut is supposed to
work in a very sequential fashion and
there's a time frame that's supposed to
happen and like our GI empty time's
supposed to be about three or four hours
and then food is supposed to slowly wind
its way through our small intestines
when you hack that with liquid sugar or
protein powder or flour you know all the
foods made out of flour you know there's
this high surface sir it overwhelms the
system in a lot of ways and we have this
sort of differential uh impact on
something called the incretion hormones
and that leads to metabolic
dysregulation in some way too much
insulin too much glucagon you know you
know different signaling and over time
you know that tends to to harm us not to
mention the fact that a lot of the
ingredients in there
cause problems with our gut health in
general there's something called
increased gut permeability or or uh
yeah or uh the Leaky guts phenomenon
which I think is very real and it does
impact us so when people hear that
you're an athlete I think that they
expect you to be taking a pre-workout uh
maybe some creatine uh protein powder
a multivitamin fish oil you know he's
good on the line basically just walk
around like a GNC store uh you take none
of it or okay I did I mean I did I did
that all three years and it was probably
I probably made some very expensive
urine over the years but
um yeah I you know literally I eat a
bunch of steak and eggs and drink water
and have some some salt and and that's
that's it I mean I've literally broken
World Records on that with that with
that sort of uh regimen
Jewels who say hey I can't put on weed I
can't you know do XYZ thing that I want
to accomplish with my body uh just
through food that's why I take the
protein powder that's why I take the
creatine that's why I take whatever
are they are they full of [ __ ] do they
not understand something is it no
actually if you want
unrealistic human goals then you're
gonna have to take somebody like how do
you think about those individuals well I
mean you know if you look at the average
bodybuilder this is not a normal human
physique I mean particularly ones who've
taken all the drugs I mean in fact you
know me being at six five to 260 is kind
of a little weird anyway but
um you know so you're pushing the the
bounds of physiology to be a super big
athlete right a lot of muscle it's just
not you know if you go out and look at
these you know indigenous tribes there's
nobody jacked running around there you
know they're lean and they're not too
fat but they're not running around like
they're you know uh you know on a
bodybuilding stage and so to get there
you have to sort of hack your physiology
and so sometimes
um you've got to eat to a point where
it's not fun anymore you know I mean if
you look at these you know big giant
strongman guys I mean they're eating
eight nine ten thousand calories they
don't like it it's not fun for them you
think oh I get to eat as much as I want
but they're literally struggling to
constantly e is one of the is just as
hard for them as training is and so
constantly having to eat when you're not
hungry you know it's fun for about a day
or two and then it then it kind of
grinds on you the other thing is you
know like with my DOT and in fact that's
why so many people have success of
losing weight it's hard to eat six seven
eight pounds of steak a day I mean this
is hard I mean I've done it it's really
really challenging I mean I top out
around four pounds and I'm like I'm good
I don't need how many calories is that
for me it's about 4 000 calories which
is pretty much on par if you do if you
put my stats into a you know a uh metal
block rate calculator that's about what
I'm supposed to use so I'm it's the
average of course is probably like two
thousand yeah I mean well I mean the
average you know I have like like
somebody you probably like 2800
something like that so you're looking at
about two and a half pounds of steak a
day which is you know you think of that
and you're like well that's a lot of
food but it's not really I mean it's not
that many calories but you you'd feel
very satisfied with that yeah uh you
mentioned water uh do you drink out of
water bottles are you worried about
Plastics like as you think about health
what what is uh what's kind of view
there I mean I think there's something
to it I mean I think you know we are
being exposed to plastic is that the big
picture piece I think that's a minor
player quite honestly I think think you
know would I rather eat steak and drink
on a plastic water bottle or would I
rather eat you know Oreos and drink out
of a glass container you know clearly I
think the steak one would be make more
sense so there's some things that I
think are clearly there I don't think
that's the biggest player I don't think
these pla these Plastics
while we should you know if if it's no
difference just to drink out of a glass
container
then that's that's a that's a minor
sacrifice to you right so why not make
sense but uh to sit there and think that
all your problems are related because
you ate drank out of a plastic bottle to
me doesn't make sense yeah it's uh kind
of one of these things of like hey uh I
don't eat healthy uh I don't work out
right right but I took this vitamin
right right right right you know that's
the thing it's like people don't want to
do the basics you know it's like there's
no pill I don't care if it's a
pharmaceutical drug or a supplement that
is going to make you a healthy person if
you don't have all these other healthy
basic behaviors in place when you go to
a restaurant I'm assuming you order
steak any special instructions or
anything that you ask them to do so that
uh you feel like it's healthier
you know generally not I mean if I'm
going out a restaurant I I accept that
what it's going to cost more than I'd
spend at home two it's not going to be
probably as good as what I can make at
home in many cases depending where it is
and so I don't worry I'm not like hyper
hyper sensitive about all this stuff I'm
pretty you know it's like hey you just
do the best you can and don't you know
like I said it's it's not for me a
religion it's not you know like I said
well you know a lot of people say it's
just like veganism but the opposite
Spectrum it's not it's not really
because we're not really out there
there's no ideology attached to this at
least in my view so if you know if if
the state comes with a little you know
uh herb butter on there or something
like that's fine no big deal I'll have
that and it's not a not a big issue like
I said I think it's what you do the vast
majority of time is gonna have all the
the impact now there's some people you
know if you've got this horrible
autoimmune disease you've got Crohn's
disease or something you know that's
multiple sclerosis or something like you
have to be super tight about this you
know then you're gonna have to be more
cautious about that but you know for the
general person it just wants to be
healthy you know I think generally I go
order a steak at a restaurant I know
they're going to probably cook it you
know they probably got it in you know
canola oil and they probably got some
sugar on you know that's that's how they
do to make it taste good right yeah
that's what they do so I know I'll be
getting that to a little degree and I
don't eat out that much to be honest you
know I just kind of I've gotten to the
point where
you know is it is it worth it you know
like like I said we're here on vacation
the first thing I do is I hit the
grocery store load up on a bunch of
steaks I got I've got a grill in the
backyard we rented a little Airbnb and
that test works well yeah
um when you go to the grocery store
grass-fed not certain Cuts like what
what are you maybe more worried about
and trying to say hey if I get the big
decisions right obviously just getting
steak sounds like that's a big decision
are the other things that uh you try to
focus on yeah that's a great question
and so I really focus on if I'm gonna
like it or not I mean honestly I mean
I'm going to eat it I want it to taste
good so I think that's that's number one
I mean and that's really what drives
most of our decision making you think
about what people think about when they
they pick food it's like how much does
it cost what does it taste like I mean
that's what driving 95 of the food
decisions in this country and I think
that's still a very important thing and
so I will eat both grass finish and
grain finish I think the differences on
those on human health are minuscuely
different there's not much difference in
fact the literature and I've looked into
this tremendously and I'm a huge
proponent of regenerative agriculture
and I'm always is promoting those guys
and support your local ranchers and I
think that's great message but when
we're talking to the general population
you can afford it would taste good to
you steak is a hundred times better than
Cheerios I mean it's just that's just
the bottom line it doesn't matter if it
comes from Walmart from uh from a you
know feedlot it's still a health food
and uh the data and the data I've
collected did from Harvard University
all supports that and until until some
definitive studies are done showing that
that's not the case and so what I'm
going to tell people I'd like it there's
a there's a researcher out in at Utah
State Stefan Stefan Bond Elite who's
doing this research trying to see if
there's a difference between the two
thus far there's been about two or three
studies I've done so far they haven't
been able to show any significant
differences between the two types what
about eggs anything there that you uh
pay attention to I you know I will I
mean I think they're the one uniqueness
about a ruminant animal so a cow it has
you know a quote-unquote four stomachs
or four chambers and you know goats and
deer and sheep they uniquely are able to
really detoxify when what they eat so at
them so the even even things like
glyphosate which is on everything right
now mammals in particular are able to
metabolize it so it doesn't really show
up in their in their products so if
you're worried about pesticide exposure
like glyphosate then don't eat grains
don't eat legumes all the things they're
telling me because they're they're
pretty much covered in them at a much
higher rate uh whether or not that's
truly a problem or not that's debatable
some people say it destroys your gut
microbiome you know on and on some
people say it's not an issue but
um yeah so when I uh you know
when I uh buy buy the food in the store
I just look for something that looks
good I think fat content is important
I'm not eating carbohydrates so I have
to uh I have to get my energy from
somewhere right so so fat content
becomes important that's why grain
finished tends to have a little more fat
in there and it tends to be a little
more monounsaturated fat than saturated
fat for people that care about that and
then like on the eggs uh front like cage
yeah yeah I mean that's the point of the
room I think so a chicken a pig they're
monogastric animals are like us you got
one stomach they tend to maybe
accumulate more problematic issues from
what they eat so it probably makes more
so if you're going to spend an extra two
bucks on on grass-finished steak versus
cage or organic eggs I'd spend it on the
eggs interesting and when you go and you
uh are cooking this is there anything to
the finish of the steak in terms of like
heat uh uh medium medium rare anything
there that has like a health impact uh
well so it's interesting so there's been
there's actually a study out there on
pigs eating ribeye steaks believe it or
not you look at how pigs eating rib eye
steaks and they cook them to various
different temperatures and they want to
see what the protein absorption was like
and they found I think a medium rib eye
steak had the most absorption and there
was some other for some reason bologna
was absorbed pretty well and I think
rare ground beef actually showed quite a
bit of absorption so it's kind of all
over the place
um I think a well done steak is a
tragedy I think you're dishonoring the
animal for that so I and I live with
someone who likes her steaks well done
it always pains me when I have to cook
her steaks well done I'm always just
like you know so she doesn't I often I
hope she's not listening I won't give
her my high-end stuff I'll give yours
could have a well done let's just cook
one of these cheap steaks
um I you know but I mean there are some
there is some evidence that maybe some
of the nutrients are a little better
preserved if they're not you know turned
into leather right so medium rare I mean
that's what most Jess will prefer you
know like I'll plant in France in
Spanish you know that's because that's
supposed to be supposed to be prepared
that way I like a nice sear on the steak
I mean like probably most of us do it
just tastes good human beings have been
cooking steaks over fires for
arguably hundreds of thousands of years
if not millions of years depending on
your your particular bias
um so yeah I'll I mean the way I cook my
steaks I sous vide them at about 125
degrees and then I put them in an oven
that goes to 1500 degrees I got this 1
500 degree oven at home that
been nice here and a little bit of salt
and that's that's it that's good for me
like eight minutes ten minutes total
well I mean if you don't count the
sous-vide time it's you know because
I'll I'll often throw it in the sous
vide and go do something you know
whatever and I'll leave it in there
until I'm ready to cook the steak and
but it takes about three minutes to heat
up the grill and it takes about a minute
per side so I'm you know it's five
minutes prep time and then I'm eating
yeah pretty simple
um you've mentioned a couple times now
kind of ancestors uh early humans I
think a lot of people look at the
carnivore diet they try to make uh um
some sort of connection there right you
buy that don't buy that do you think it
matters what our ancestors say well I
mean I think that you know
yeah it can inform us a little bit I
mean you wouldn't take zebras and bring
them to the zoo and say why don't we go
let's go grocery shopping with the zebra
you're gonna look at what they were
eating and you would say this is what
they're supposed to eat right so the
problem is how do we don't have a time
machine so we can't definitively go back
and say humans we're eating this or that
and there's always a debate about that I
mean there's pretty good evidence we are
clearly meat eaters I mean there's you
know cave paintings there's cut marks on
Bones there's radioisotope status on you
know data on and on it shows that humans
consume a lot of meat
um but at the end of the day like I live
in 2022 I gotta do what works for me
today and so this you know I like I said
it doesn't really matter so much what
they ate back then as far as what how it
affects me today but you know what they
but what they ate back then could inform
me what we might be eating what it can
show you is what we weren't eating I
mean clearly none of us were eating uh
canola oil 50 000 a year even 500 years
ago we know those if no one was eating
Twinkies no one was eating Doritos no
one was eating you know uh you know
Honey Bunches of Oats or whatever
whatever you pick your food I mean none
of that stuff existed right so if we
know that then we can say well you know
maybe they were eating meat maybe they
were eating berries maybe they're eating
some tubers if you limit your diet to
just that gosh you know you're going to
be at least more in line with your
species you know like the only obese
creatures on the planet are human beings
and our pets right these are the only
obese animals that exist well why is
that almost because we feed them stuff
they're not supposed to eat
it's crazy to think it's that simple we
talked how to prepare and and cook a
steak what about the eggs anything there
that matters or anything you prefer uh I
end up drinking half of them I mean
honestly I throw them in a blender and I
throw it and I'll throw a little bit of
flavor in there I'll throw a little like
uh
vanilla in that you know and I just I'll
drink them down so you hold on rewind
you'll take six eight ten eggs whatever
you'll crack them just throw it throw in
throw the blender on for a few seconds
yeah and I'll usually add water to that
just give a little more volume just to
kind of fill me up a little more but um
yeah I'll just drink it I mean if I'm in
a hurry you know if I feel like cooking
it sometimes I'll do that but I've
gotten to where I'm I've just gotten
more and more laziest time has gone by
around cooking I'm just like so it's
basically raw egg it is yeah yeah and
and it's fine I mean it's well I mean
the risk of you to catching a an issue
like salmonella is a concern about one
out of every 20 000 eggs will have a
contamination with salmon a lot of times
you can detect it so odds are pretty low
I mean I
even though I probably eat you know
a thousand eggs a year for if not more
I've not even had enough opportunity to
run into that issue so it's not it's not
really a big concern okay uh if you do
prepare the egg what do you do I'll I'll
either uh scramble it you know or I
might just kind of fry it up so what
whatever the fastest way to yeah
whatever I'm in the mood for you know
like I said I eat what I like you know
it's not I'm not I'm I don't you know I
don't sit there and you know there's
some people their life is so
dictated by trying to live forever you
know but first i'm gonna get up in the
morning and I'm gonna then I'm gonna I'm
gonna meditate and then I'm gonna growl
and then I'm gonna face whatever
Direction and I'm gonna walk in the Sun
and then I'm gonna spend 15 minutes of
red lights there and I'm gonna jump in
my cold plunge and my saw you know you
see these people there and it's like
when you have time to do anything you
know it's just kind of like so I I'm
kind of like hey if I feel like it I'll
do it you know and it's it's it the nice
thing about it so simple it's a
Simplicity it just kind of simplifies
things to where I don't have to
constantly worry about all these other
other extraneous things so we talked
about uh what you're putting in your
body which is not much
um but very simple uh what about in the
gym what are you doing there and why do
you do it well I mean I think this is uh
you know when we talk about longevity
and health and whatever you want to talk
about I think quality life has to come
into effect there and functional lean
mass is incredibly important as we get
older you know I'm you know like I said
I'm closer to 60 than I am 50. it's very
important for my quality of life to be
able to do things and to do things like
I could when I was my 20s and so part of
that equation is you know obviously
eating right getting adequate sleep uh
but you know resistance training is
incredibly important and so I focus on
you know getting stronger basic heavy
compound movements I focus on being able
to move well so a lot of jumping and
sprinting and throwing I do some
conditioning stuff so it's mostly I
prefer to do what's called Sprint animal
training or high intensity interval
training because just from a time time
management standpoint rather than and
then I'll go for a walk I'll take my
dogs for a walk you know we live out in
the woods out in Washington state so
we'll go for a couple times a day I'll
go for a couple mile hike with the
doggos if I can and that's usually my my
routine in general now
um you know if I'm competing like right
now I took up Jiu Jitsu so I'm you know
I'm kind of focusing some of the
training uh to hopefully benefit benefit
me in that if I'm wrong if I'm competing
and rolling then I'll be a lot of rowing
thrown on top of that and so but I like
to be able to uh not only be strong but
able to move well I think that's
important how many hours a day you think
you're doing physical activity uh well I
mean that's a great question so I think
sedentary activity like you know sitting
here like we're doing now is detrimental
like like when I'm at home usually I'm
standing when I do these types of things
uh so but as far as actual like working
out type stuff Dr Baker just said I'm
killing him
I'm just we'll make up for it later no I
mean I I spend probably
um actually like working out working out
less than an hour a day you know
sometimes sometimes only 15 minutes
depending on what I'm what I'm doing but
I try to minimize the sedentary behavior
and I think if most people would do that
you know if you can like say instead of
sitting standing if you you know instead
of standing walking like if you're on a
business call
take if you can take the phone and go
for a walk that's gonna that's gonna
stead you most of your caloric
expenditure is with this non-exercise
activity thermogenesis so-called neat
that's where probably you know 45 of
your calorie expenditure is going to
come from so whatever you're doing in
the gym unless you're you know unless
you're four five six hours a day in the
gym which is not practical for you know
anybody but a professional athlete you
know then it's just minimizing your
sedation or you're sorry sedentary
Behavior yeah uh standing desk uh you
just try to stand there all day you have
like a walking uh treadmill thing yeah
people have like yeah I mean no I just
stand I'll Stand and if I want to go for
a walking like I said I I have this
wonderful exercise piece of exercise
equipment called a dog and you know that
that works pretty well you know take for
a walk a couple times a day so that's
that works out pretty well for me yeah
um in the gym you mentioned uh the
compound movements uh is it high rep
compound movements or are you just
trying to put as much weight on the bar
and do it you know two three times like
how do you think about like your
philosophy yeah so like I said I'm you
know like I said I'm 56 years old and I
have gotten away from really really
heavy heavy repetitions like when I was
powerlifting like back in my 30s I was
dead lifting close to 800 pounds I was
and that's a drug-free athlete as well
just to put that aside that that in
there I don't do those super heavy lifts
now but I still I'll still put you know
400 450 500 pounds of the bar I do 810
reps with that
um I tend to stay in a little bit higher
rep range right now but I mean the you
know the data on this shows that
um as long as you're able to you know
Produce close to momentary muscular
failure or you know you're doing reps
until you start to struggle or you know
you're getting close to failing that's
that's all you got to do doesn't matter
how much weight's on the bar for most
things I mean this is an average you
know if you're tailored for strength
training versus bodybuilding there's
some nuances there but in general I just
try to push myself pretty hard and
usually I pick kind of a moderate weight
for that uh you mentioned sprinting
earlier I don't think a lot of people
would say hey uh a guy who's almost 60
years old or closing in on 60 is still
doing sprints it's still doing some of
things that they would assign to younger
athletic uh people who are trying to
compete for actual sports sporting just
kind of sucks like I think a lot of
people just like I just don't enjoy it
um talk a little bit about the cardio
component is sprinting the main
component or the other thing she'll do
well first of all I think older people
should be doing some foreign sprinting I
mean I think that's that's incredibly
important uh you know it's from just
from a time management standpoint but
yeah the the you know if we look at sort
of VO2 max which is a measure of our
cardiorespiratory Fitness we know that
short Sprint intervals are very
effective at developing that so there's
like you know just even on a bike it
doesn't even have to go out and run hill
Sprints I do that too but I'll get on a
bike and I'll just crank you know five
ten seconds Sprints as hard as I
possibly can I I call them chainsaw
Sprints I pretend you know the Texas
Chainsaw Massacre dudes chasing me and I
you know go as fast as I can for you
know five or ten seconds because we can
only truly Sprint for about 10 seconds
this is when we change from different
Energy Systems you know if you try to
sprint on a bike you know more than
about 20 seconds you just start slowing
down there's no way you can maintain
that because we switched from this pure
sort of ATP creatine phosphate system
over to analog anaerobic glycolysis or
you know are mostly that way and you
know you just you just don't have the
power output so I like to keep when we
talk about this term high intensity
interval training the intensity has to
be high and the only way intensity can
be high is if it's short because you
can't you I don't care who you are
you're going to run out of gas soon you
know you're getting a fight and you run
if somebody runs out of gas after about
15 seconds of you know uh you know
swinging and stuff like that so
um that is you know the way our body is
designed there's no changing that in the
human species and so I try to capitalize
on that so it's Sprint adequate recovery
and that's the other thing that people
run into they fail to give themselves
adequate recovery so if you're doing a
10 second Sprint you probably need five
times as much recovery time 50 seconds
so 10 seconds on 50 second sauce every
minute on the minute that works out
pretty well you can do that five rounds
you're done in five minutes so that's a
that's a that's an effective way to do
that uh on the topic of recovery you've
mentioned sleep a couple times it sounds
like that's pretty important what do you
do there
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep good sleep is a game changer and
the eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine I sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod 3 you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees Fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees Fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
an eat sleep you can go to eatsleep.com
pump today to go ahead and get 150 off
your order eightsleep.com pump not only
do I sleep on it every night it
literally changed my life and I begged
the founders to let me invest in the
company eightsleep.com go get yourself
an eight sleep pod and get a better
night of sleep uh well if I can remember
close your eyes yeah well I can try if I
try to you know keep keep the damn phone
out of my my hands and that type of
stuff I get a pretty good night's sleep
like I mentioned earlier uh not eating
real late helps me quite a bit um you
know how having just kind of a you know
just a general routine you know we sleep
hygiene if you don't know cool room dark
room Electronics off you know uh not
engaging in any kind of stressful
activities over a period of time you
know it's like uh you know going out and
running Sprints before you go to bed
it's not going to work very well right
so you're kind of trying to just have
this sort of routine where you kind of
slow things down
um I find that you know at this point
about seven hours is is adequate for me
and this is interesting thing about this
diet is most people will find their
sleep is much higher quality the volume
is a little bit less and I know most of
the studies out there show eight hours
plus seems to be ideal for longevity but
interestingly uh I sleep really well I
sleep extremely well generally uh and
when I wake up I feel I've got plenty of
energy why do you think the diet has
that impact where you still get really
high quality sleep you feel energized so
it kind of sleep did its job but it's
actually a shorter period of time right
right so if we look at and there are
some studies on for instance both very
low carb diets and look at the the the
phases of sleep you know we've got these
different phases REM sleep and non-rem
sleep and deep sleep they show that low
carbohydrate more people spend time in
the Deep Sleep range and so that you
know arguably more restorative the other
thing is if we look at why are we
sleeping and there's a lot of reasons
why we do that but some of the reasons
are we're you know it's kind of repair
it's kind of this repair process that's
going on so we're you know we're
basically dealing with all these
reactive oxygen species that have kind
of developed through the day so we've
got these antioxidant systems kind of
revved up and taking care of that stuff
well on the diet we tend to like a lower
carb diet tends to produce less of these
reactive oxygen species so we have less
just damage to deal with the other thing
is uh like if I'm like about one to two
percent of our muscle mass is turning
over every day and then our you know our
Skin's turning over our gut lining is
turning over all these tissues are
constantly turning over and what do they
need to rebuild those things well I mean
the the simplest way to look at this is
you know you and I are basically animals
we have animal cells and our animals
cells you know if we look at the
individual components of that where do
we get the building blocks from well if
you provide other animal cells in there
you're going to have the act the actual
ratios and the amounts that you need so
I'm probably doing less damage and I'm
providing myself higher quality
nutrition to help repair the damage so
probably I need a little bit less sleep
with that regard you know like I said if
you're trying to build a brick house and
you know you have a big pile of bricks
here you're like well that's pretty good
or you got straw and mud you're like
well I got to make the straw and but
it's going to be less efficient to do it
this way so this is why
um you know a carnivorous approach tends
to be more efficient in fact if we look
at the history of planet Earth and all
the animals that have ever existed all
things have swam crawled or flown on
Earth something like 80 percent of them
are carnivorous you know through all all
the time that you're there because it's
more efficient it's easier yeah when you
think about sleep there's a lot of
people who have all kinds of crazy sleep
routines uh they drink teas they use
melatonin CBD like all these things
things that some people swear by some
people say hey I'll dabble when I need
it whatever what's your general read
after having so many different patients
and kind of even testing on yourself all
these different protocols well I think
that honestly most of them probably you
can't extract you can't you can't
generalize it to the population I mean
I'm not going to say somebody says hey I
do this and I sleep or I'm not going to
you know disagree with that person but I
don't think there's any really great
data you can say this is definitely
going to lead to a better night there's
a lot of things we know that disrupts
sleep we don't feel like for instance
alcohol we know it's a sleep disruptor
we know that intense exercise you know
you know our you know stress all those
things are going to disrupt sleep and so
as far as can I take this magic pill and
so I mean obviously there's a whole
bunch of people that are taking Ambien
and you know Zoloft and all these
otherwise but Ambien and all these other
sleep meds uh that initially work and
then over time they stop working and
then over time you become where you're
dependent upon those things and so I
think that uh you know sleep is a
product of needing sleep and you need
sleep by you know using your body to
where it's supposed to be so if you're
sedentary all day laying on the couch
all day you wonder why you can't fall
asleep because you haven't done anything
in 2020 uh like most people life gets
disrupted and I started paying a lot
more attention to what am I eating what
am I drinking what am I doing whatever
and that was one of uh the dumbest yet
most profound breakthroughs for me was
like you will sleep better if you are
tired
and it's so simple but uh even when you
talk to people who uh are focused on
exercise or diet or whatever it's just
never like just doing a physical
exercise until you actually want to go
to sleep and uh what I found for me
personally is like if I'm tired around
8pm I won't go to sleep at eight right I
just it's hard for me to do that uh but
I know like yeah I moved enough today
and you and you then you have the better
night sleep you wake up and so is there
anything to this kind of like uh The
rhythms of sleep the time of day you go
to sleep the time of day you wake up how
do you think about all that and what do
you do well I mean there there's clearly
uh science on this topic you know we
know we know that melatonin production
increases you know uh as the sun's going
down and so we know the light plays a
role as some people say well look my
people like to watch the sunset you know
this is a well you got the sunrise on
this side of the coast but if you lived
on you lived in Tampa you could go out
there and watch the sunset
um light has an impact on this and so if
we're in there and we're staring at TVs
or looking at our phones that's kind of
that's going to impact our melatonin
production so there is definitely a
circadian biology circadian rhythm
that's associated with this and so you
know you see that you know it's like
eight o'clock you're kind of sleepy but
then if you go screw around on your on
the internet for two hours and all of a
sudden you're Wide Awake again because a
light light Rhythm has disrupted that
and then you know then you don't go to
sleep till one o'clock in the morning or
something like I said you know you start
to get that that natural Sundown effect
and then if you just kind of if you just
say hey this means I'm supposed to be
getting ready for bed and if you
actually stick to that you're probably
going to sleep better but if instead you
say okay let me go watch a movie or go
play a video game or yell at somebody on
the internet you know you've disrupted
that yeah you mentioned earlier you're
waking up at four or five o'clock in the
morning uh is that something you still
do how do you think about waking up
super early in the morning versus if you
woke up at you know yeah I never need an
alarm clock anymore so I think for some
reason you know maybe it's a general
lifestyle in the lifestyle in general or
perhaps the nutrition has a rule on this
but I am very much tied to the sun you
know I mean when the sun is starting to
come up I just feel you know we have
this natural biology where we have a
surge of cortisone and a cortisol in the
morning we have our testosterone
increases our production of glucose
increases that's you know because we go
from this very very Placid state of
sleep to all of a sudden arousal and
there's hormones that are that are that
are just hardwired into you know every
mammal's physiology that you know every
every uh
non-uh you know uh nocturnal animal uh
is going to start experiencing that and
that's you just kind of suddenly wake so
I literally I wake up probably within 30
minutes plus or minus the sunrise either
before or after pretty much regulate you
mentioned earlier autoimmune disease
um there's a bunch of uh research and
also reasons as to why people develop
these or have them what are the ones
that you would put the most weight on
are there genetic arguments are there
lifestyle arguments are there uh well
clearly autoimmune diseases are
increasing in frequency that's not a
genetic shift I mean you can just like
we look at obesity you know you're
looking at well it's my genes well
people in the 1920s have the same genes
as you but they weren't you know 50 of
the population wasn't obese at that time
so what we're seeing is a dramatic
increase in autoimmune diseases you know
they tend to favor females for some
reason
um it is increasing dramatically I think
it's very likely that most of that is
caused by external if something external
probably it originates in the gut we see
this so-called gut dysfunction which is
very closely tied with autoimmune
disease many people that have one Auto
and immune immune disease we'll have two
or three because they have the same
underlying biology and so what we see
and what I've seen with our company and
another group that's done some similar
work is that if you can fix the gut
physiology the autoimmune diseases often
will remit will go away the inflammatory
markers will drive down and they'll
become symptom-free you mentioned gut uh
explain for people a little bit more
detail uh what is it exactly that's off
on the gut and why is the gut what's
driving right so if we look at you know
like our uh relationship to the
environment like what is the biggest
interface we have with the environment
well most of us say our skin Riders
games and organs the biggest organ we
have we're touching the environment but
the skin is designed to keep things out
right we don't want you know if we have
a cut in our skin then we have problems
with an infection our gut is the
opposite our gut is designed to bring
things in that's what we you know most
people don't know this but between
between our mouth and our and our butt
that's all external to our environment
that's outside of our body technically
the way our body performs you know
performs it you know from an embryo is
basically circles around this this empty
tube and that's still external to our
body so most of our immune system is our
gut and the gut is designed like I said
to absorb everything and so whatever
we're exposed to environmentally is
going to come to us through the gut
largely and so any problems within our
external environment uh the gut will
mediate was going through there and so
the gut has a selective barrier so it
can say these things come in these
things stay out right unfortunately over
time exposure probably to the modern you
know modern junk food diet that barrier
starts to break down and we have this
selective hyperpermeability of AKA leaky
gut so now we're absorbing things we're
not supposed to absorb and so that leads
to an inflammatory response an immune
response a lot of times autoimmunity is
associated with that there's a reason
researcher out of Boston's Boston
Children's Hospital by the name of
Alessia faisano who's published fairly
extensive extensively on the
relationship between gut dysfunction and
autoimmunity it seems to hold up and
that's what we see all the time as far
as if you restore gut permeability to
its normal situation the markers of
autoimmune disease tend to go down as do
the symptoms and I see people reversing
Crohn's disease also colitis psoriasis
rheumatoid arthritis multiple sclerosis
certain asthma uh you know
eczema on and on and on all kinds of
things improve how does somebody know
that their gut's messed up is there a
test that they can take is there
something that they can do is it
something they feel that like hey that's
probably a gut problem well I mean you
know honestly you know we and I didn't
notice for for 50 years you know when
you would eat something you know Sam it
kind of swells up a little bit you fit
to get discovered you think that's
normal that's like that's just eating
we're experiencing it you get gas you're
belching you're farting all this stuff
you think well that's just kind of
normal physiology it's actually not uh
that either indicates you the food
you're eating is wrong or your gut is
messed up so that's that's a pretty
clear sign if you've got you know if
you've got chronic diarrhea and all
those things you you're going to know it
already
um there are you know like I said
there's a group in in Europe that does
something called a peg 400 which is a
polyethylene glycol glycol test where
you drink this and they can see what
appears in your yard and that's that's a
way to assess gut permeability but
um generally your digestion like you
know I had two and a half pounds of rib
eye steak became before I came here I
literally don't don't even know I ate I
mean I literally don't feel anything and
that that was that was one of the
biggest shocks to me is when I went from
you know years of you know you'd eat
something then two hours later you're
like ah you know my stomach's a little
sore you know I gotta go to the bathroom
when you go from that chronically to
it's like nothing it's like it's like
you know if you uh you know if you give
some of these noise canceling headphones
the first time you put them on you're
like wow it's really quiet in here
that's the same sort of sensation you
get so your gut is not
it shouldn't feel like it's problematic
like like I said if you were you know
walking down the street and all of a
sudden your lungs hurt or your heart
hurt or your knees hurt you would say
that's a problem that's not healthy but
people accept the fact that they're you
know you got a sore stomach you know
you're bloated you're gassy we accept
that as normal and it's actually not
yeah
people make this
just food or the other things there's
I've seen probiotics I've seen all sorts
of uh kombucha you can imagine the the
kind of uh closer to the hippie places
of town you get crazier and crazier
things uh from my opinion does any of
that stuff work or is it just literally
just eat the right Foods well I think
you know it's like it's like if you have
um you know this is the funny thing
somebody come in and have arthritis in
their knee and you give them an
anti-inflammatory right and it helps
right
the question you ask is why are you
inflamed in the first place
well I know no one ever asked that you
never asked your doctor you know it's
like oh well here take this pill and and
that's as far as it goes most most
Physicians aren't even curious about
that but I think a lot of these things
were this turmeric or you know whatever
whatever you know whatever Elderberry
sauce or you know they've got all these
things you can do all that probably is
used to mitigate problems that are being
caused by the foods you're consuming in
the first place so if you're not you
know it's like I've got a headache we'll
stop hitting your head against the wall
right that's simple advice but no people
just rather take to take the pill of the
supplement so we are constantly trying
to plug holes in a leaky diet you know
we're eating a diet that is you know
really not well suited to us I mean
certainly the modern diet you know
certainly all this high qual high in
that quality high calorie nutrient poor
food where you're constantly trying to
plug holes in because you're just always
nutrient deficient so I think and you're
always in Flames you're taking an
anti-inflammatory and you're trying to
mask these symptoms so why not remove
all the inflammatory stuff the the uh
improve the quality of nutrition and you
don't need all these things yeah are
there things that people would consider
healthy uh fruits vegetables things like
that that also are creating inflammation
like I think I read one time uh Tom
Brady and the whole like tb12 there's a
big thing around like tomatoes yeah and
supposedly he's not eating that stuff
because he thinks it could inflate yeah
I mean it's so-called nightshade
vegetables
um have have had a bad rap and in fact
you know there was a period in time
where Tomatoes were considered like
deadly I mean there was there was a
period like three 400 years ago where
there's a big you know pushback against
tomatoes and so
I think for certainly for some people
I'm not here to say that all fruits and
vegetables are bad and poison I know
there's people out there within this
community that say that I always cringe
when I hear that because I'm trying to
say look this is this is for Selective
people but I think that one I think we
have this phenomenon of everybody's gut
is being destroyed by the modern food
system you know 20 of us have IBS
clinically diagnosed IBS and probably
irritable bowel syndrome and
um probably more have that subclinically
they have not been diagnosed so we've
got all this underlying pathology and so
we're already in a situation where guts
are are broken uh and then you add these
Foods in there that maybe 100 years ago
we would have tolerated fine but now
people aren't aren't tolerating that and
it's causing issues because all the
plants that do have some toxic you know
that that's not even controversial to
say that you know apple seeds have have
uh cyanide in it we know that we know
that tannins and uh glycoloids and
lectins and you know phytic acids all
those things have a potential for
negative issues now generally it's low
dose such a small thing that it's not an
issue for most people but as the gut
gets more and more uh destroyed with a
modern diet then these things become I
think we have less resilience to deal
with those things and so what I see is
there's people that'll go on
a whole food diet you know and it might
be just clean no junk food no sugar no
no processed food they're eating you
know Seafood a little bit of meat you
know fruits and vegetables and you think
that's a great diet you know and I think
for many people it would be but they
still have issues and then they
eliminate all the fruits and vegetables
they used to eat just meat and they do
better and I'm like well that's it is
what it is I'm not there to say that's
bad or good it just is what it is and so
for some people that's clearly an issue
now what I like to see is you know if
somebody goes three six months they do
this Elimination Diet
and they solve all those issues
hopefully they can add those things back
in because you know I think everybody
should be able to eat food they enjoy
um as you talk about the modern diet one
of the things that jumps to mind is uh
the invention of the toilet may actually
be uh screwing over uh health and so uh
somebody sent me an article once and
they were like oh yeah we're all pooping
wrong and I was like wait hold on a
second what do you mean and basically
what they were like well if you look at
other cultures you know take India or
whatever uh literally the position in
which someone takes a [ __ ] is completely
different than here in America where
they're sitting you know kind of
perpendicular uh their thighs to the
ground and so I've seen I think maybe
even on Shark Tank I've seen articles
written about things that uh people will
put their feet on as they're pooping in
the toilet to lift their legs because
it's supposed to put them in a different
position I've had friends who live in
other countries be like what are you
Americans doing
what is the uh the view maybe that you
have in terms of like is it something
with the gut is it could be like the way
that we're pooping or is it all [ __ ]
and people just want something to talk
about on the internet I think it's
mostly [ __ ] I mean honestly I mean
yeah I mean I think the toilet is
actually I mean sewage systems you know
it's it's really good greatly improved
the quality health for Humanity I mean
you know the the biggest impacts for
life expectancy have been sanitation and
access to to fresh water
um you know I mean you know there's
something people talk about how we birth
kids you know I used to be they would
burn them sitting up you know I've seen
some guy give an electron that so I
think there may be some
slight validity to that do I think
that's the root cause of all of our
problems why we're all obese and have
chronic disease and cancer because we're
not pooping right no I don't think
that's it I think you know maybe you can
make a slight art you know it may be
nice that you can you know I mean the
one thing is you know I made a post on
Twitter the other day about this as we
accommodate illness and obesity we
create more of it and so the fact that I
can go to the bathroom and not have to
get into a full squat then I never have
to squat down all the way then I never
need to do that and all that happens to
my knee health over over the 10 20 years
I lose some of that cartilage in the
back of my knee never sees stress and so
it probably starts to flake off uh so I
think indirectly you know people that
sit in a full Squad all the time are
going to have generally better Fitness I
mean it's hard to do that when you're
200 pounds overweight I mean it just
doesn't happen so if all the toilets
were turned into like little holes like
they have in China
there'd be a lot less happy obese people
now I'm not saying we should we should
antagonize them but I mean the reality
of the situation is it would be really
hard to live life in that situation
whereas right now we've got mobility
scooters we've got people handing you
medications we've got you know we don't
we've got ubereats we've got we make it
so easy to be basically disabled which
is I think facilitating that yes it's
interesting that in some way if you had
to do basic physical functions without
society which has been amazing and we
live in this great civilization uh
accommodating you not doing it that you
actually may just be in Better Health
from your day-to-day life and you
wouldn't have to uh uh put such a big
focus on your diet or your exercise or
whatever because you're just moving
around yeah no I think that's that's
completely valid and I think we've
gotten to a point where
I mean I know there's this transhumanist
movement some people are saying it's you
know we're all going to be these super
computer people but really we're going
to be like these dependent you know I
don't know integrated blobs you know to
sit there and I don't know maybe our
brains are harvested for some for some
purpose yeah Founders fund has a uh a
quote they say you know we were promised
flying cars we got 140 characters a
similar thing right we're promised like
the singularity for this that we are
just fat and dying
um talk a little bit about quality of
life over time as well uh I I I it's the
topic I really didn't think that much
about I'm a relatively young guy healthy
um but I read a book uh being mortal by
a tune gawandi and uh he talks about how
you know here in America our experience
with old age is basically you go to an
assisted living then you go to a
retirement home uh the death experience
is inside of a hospital right you're
hooked up to all the stuff we're trying
to preserve how long can we make your
life not how good can we make it
um other countries some of them are
similar to us some of them aren't how do
you think about with some of your
patients who maybe are on the older end
do their diets change over time do you
think it's like not one size fits all of
the patient but like one size fits an
entire life and whatever works for you
at 30 or 40 should still help you
persist later in life how does that work
uh well I mean the question about does
Diet change over time as we get older I
mean in many cases it does I mean you
know we see a lot of old people they
start losing their teeth and they can't
chew harder food so they end up with a
more soft diet we see people with
dementia where you know it's interesting
there's a lot of thought that
Alzheimer's disease and other forms of
dementia are really just a form of
insulin resistance to the brain and so
the brain cannot access energy it can't
get glucose and so I saw this happen to
my grandmother in fact now a lot of
people are listening this and no
demented people will will attest to this
um as they get older and older they just
want to continue to eat high sugar foods
because they're having such a hard time
getting nutrition to their brains so all
they want to use Grandma all she wants
to eat use cake and cookies all the time
we see that occurring we see that the
protein our ability to to digest and
absorb protein goes down as we get older
now I don't know that's a direct
consequence of getting older but more so
a consequence of becoming more and more
diseased and I think if you you look at
the way we age versus just becoming more
diseased if you think about death is the
ultimate disease where finally we
succumb to uh you know an overwhelming
amount of disease State
um so it does change and I think
unfortunately we are we are uh you know
if you go if you go to if you ever have
the
you know the misfortune of spending a
lot of time in a nursing home because I
don't think they're very nice places in
general it's bismal when you see what's
going on you know everybody's in there
you know they're they're zombied out
they're just kind of sitting by
themselves they're serving them low
quality food it's very low in protein
it's high in refined uh refined Foods
carbohydrates fats and things like that
and they just circled the drain until
they finally used to come and so I think
the best thing we can do is we get older
like I said you're I think you're in
your 30s right right yeah so I mean it's
this is the time you put on a lean mass
you focus on that and that will stead
you into your 50s 60s 70s and 80s and
then you know if you get anything beyond
80 I think it's you know I think that's
a blessing you know assuming the quality
of life is good I mean I've met at
several hundred most of the 100 year old
people I've met unfortunately have all
been literally old ladies that are
demented in diapers with a broken hip I
mean that's where those are 100 years
old people I would run into and I rarely
didn't ever see any that were vital and
fit or something I'd want to emulate so
you look at this and you're like I don't
want to spend 10 years of my life just
in this absolute you know abysmal
existence and so you've got to be
mindful about what you're doing now
because you know
some people you know you start talking
to 70 year olds and talk to them about
70 year olds and you're like hey
wouldn't it be great to live to 100 and
many of them are saying Hell no because
they're miserable I mean they literally
are and it shouldn't be the case you
should be uh in my view robust
productive vigorous uh enjoying life and
then you drop dead at whatever 92 or
something like that one of the things
that I took away from that book was uh
uh there's a bunch of studies that show
like the more that you try to prolong uh
or prevent death uh the faster it may
come to some degree like if you if uh
you're in the hospital and you're
constantly pumping yourself with drugs
and this and and there's knock-on
effects of that versus uh in many cases
the doctor would say hey you got three
weeks somebody goes home six months a
year later they're still living now why
how was the doctor wrong there's a bunch
of questions uh but in some ways just
like literally go live your life be
healthy go outside do the do these what
some people just assume are simple
things uh and that may be enough and and
so you don't ever want to say that that
is the solution you shouldn't go to the
hospital right but at the same time it's
interesting to look at two different
approaches of one being very medicinal
and another just saying listen you know
it's up to you to just live your life
yeah I mean if you spend your whole all
of your waking hours trying not to die
you're not really living and so that's
the whole point here so we like I said
we get one of these and I I prefer to do
that in a healthy body that allows me to
experience the things you know at some
point like I said you've eaten enough
cupcakes and you've had enough you know
chocolate brownies but you said I know
what that tastes like I don't need to
constantly do that and if you're willing
to sort of dissociate yourself from that
part of it you get so much more in
return what about sunlight I've seen
some studies recently in some
conversation that uh actually people
aren't getting enough Sun some people
say hey uh I think like in China uh the
whiter your skin is means the less thief
in the sun which is supposed to
um uh go ahead and share that you're
wealthy or you have a high status in
society like how do you think about fun
for health purposes well I mean as a
species we evolved Under the Sun I mean
we weren't hiding in you know
air-conditioned building their whole
time so I mean we are designed to get
sunlight I mean sunlight is crucial for
vitamin production you know vitamin D
obviously is associated with sunlight
exposure we are you know a species that
is tied to the Sun so I think it does
make sense to get out there and be in
the sun to agree now you know the caveat
to that is don't get sunburned you know
if you're not getting sunburned and
you're going to have issues with skin
cancer and other things now the
interesting thing and this is a very
controversial topic we see a lot of
people when they clean up their diet
their Sun tolerance improve Crews they
don't get sunburned as easily it's not
just you can't you know I noticed like
years ago I'd spend
an hour out in the sun I'd have a pretty
good burn and now I can spend three four
hours out and I don't get burned and so
I think the diet has
does have a modific modifying effect on
our sun sun tolerance uh you say it's
controversial so uh what is your best
guess right now what the connection
between the diet and the Sun tolerances
is there something specific to point to
that you think it could well I mean one
of the one of the persons that has done
a lot of sort of look into this is a guy
he's a guy's name uh Tucker Goodrich and
he really posit that it is some of the
oils we're exposed to you know these
soybean oils canola oils things like
that uh corn oils that we've been
included in our hemodite has changed the
nature of our you know of our of our
tissue of our of our fats and so you can
actually do biopsies on humans it was
interesting when I used to operate on
people I would do either near hip
surgery and you cut them open you get
these obese people and it was it was it
was something that I observed but I
didn't know why but I would see some
people and they would have a lot of
times they'd have this very sort of
bright yellow fat you know you you'd cut
into people and it's kind of weird
talking about humans and then you cut
into some people and it'd be really it
would be it would be a really white and
almost like a like a little almost like
Rice Krispies in there just really kind
of granulated fat tissue and it's
probably based on their diet and what's
going on there and we know that like for
instance we look at animals an animal
has been finished on grass tends to have
a yellower fat and a grain finished
animal has more white fat it's probably
the same thing we're seeing in humans
and what do you think is causing the
difference in color well it's it's uh
some of it's the carotenoids that are in
there some of the some of the nutrients
that are in there is what's causing that
and uh why is yellow healthier is there
anything well I mean again it depends on
who you talk to and whether that's
healthier or not we know it's different
whether it's healthy or not I think it's
still controversial most people would
say it is
uh the uh belief is that you know this
is a natural native diet for whatever
the species is whether human beings or
uh you know cows or pigs or chickens or
whatever
uh if I Venture into meet Twitter uh and
I see people talking about meat uh
you're smirking so like uh there's a
positive negatives and everything in
between great memes uh which uh
definitely is true
um sunning your balls I've seen it over
and over and over again I've seen the
mainstream media laugh at it I've seen
them try to say it's real sunlight the
human body and just like the private
parts is there any uh seriousness to
this or you know I think it's mostly
goofy I mean I mean you know as crazy as
I may seem from a nutritional standpoint
here's this guy's [ __ ] the system and
going to its all meat diet I just don't
get into some of that so I think it's
kind of goofy I mean it's like goofy
because it's goofy like from a social
standpoint well I mean that and it's
just like I don't think it has any real
significant physiologic you know effect
I mean it's sunny here you know is sunny
your butt any better than standing out
and getting sunshine on your face I
don't know I don't know that it is right
and if the difference is it's probably
small and me and largely meaningless you
know I can think of about a thousand
things I'd rather do for my health and
and you know laying out so it might be
fun you know it might be fun to go out
there and lay out naked but you know I
always wanted to talk about it how often
they do it right some of them probably
do it every day some of them probably
don't ever do it yeah it's interesting
uh you've mentioned a lot of academic
studies uh but I also see you tweeting
on Twitter as how uh I think I started
following uh some stuff you're putting
out how do you think about like the
traditional academic world and like
traditional studies versus like Hey Joe
blow down the street you know uh posted
something and it works for me right
right the world is maybe not uh uh
blurring to the degree where people are
confusing a Twitter account for an
academic study but definitely it feels
like people are getting information from
just more than their doctor yeah sure
sure and I think I think I think it's
fair it's a fair question I think that
you know there is a value to the
scientific method in doing rigorous
studies and to exclude confounders but
we shouldn't ignore these other
observations this is how science starts
and so so if you start seeing you know
one or two people that say Hey I did
this and this happened you're like oh
that's kind of interesting then all of a
sudden that one or two starts turning
into thousands and thousands of people
then you have to start to take notice of
that that's where we're at with this
crazy all me Titan say autoimmunities I
cannot tell you how many people now who
have not only said hey look my also
colitis went away but I've got I've got
an endoscopy to prove it you know I've
got I've got four and afters so this
that's coming on and so this is how you
have to start to pay attention to these
things and and to stifle that and to say
dismiss it dismiss it dismiss it we're
only going to pay attention to uh the
status quo or the science because you
know we have this sort of belief that
you know well you might have been aware
of this this sort of stuff with this
pandemic we have this censorship to
where we have a consensus but the
consensus is produced through censorship
that's not a consensus that's just
basically a religion basically at that
point and so you know we're seeing you
know uh these you know n equals one n
equals ten n equals a thousand uh bits
of information coming it out there and
you know I've been a big champion of
that because I think that's something
people need to share their stories
because as Physicians
um if you're not paying attention to
your patients you know all your
information is coming from you know drug
companies they don't care I mean they're
they're about their their Buck you know
they you know they're they're there for
their shareholders and and so we have to
get information from where we can where
we can obtain it and so if enough people
are seeing this result
hearted deny that you know somebody's
post a picture of them at 300 pounds now
they're 150 pounds that's pretty
realistic that actually it's really
happy they did really something that
something did happen
um obviously there's a lot of emotion
tied into this you know I I as you know
I
constantly battling against the forces
of evil from the vegan Empire no I'm
just kidding I mean you know I'll say
this I think most vegans are probably
nice people but there are some that are
very very aggressive and annoying and
you know calling you a murderer and a
rapist and a you know a cow molester and
stuff like that it's like that's just
that's just silly you know
um but yeah it's it's uh you know like
like for instance uh next week in the
next two weeks I go to Nashville
Tennessee I'm meeting with the
researchers from Harvard and the U.S
Cattlemen's Association to set up a
study on autoimmunities of a bona fide
Interventional trial a high quality
study uh to to look at this stuff and I
think both of these things are important
you know when I think about what impacts
you like if I read a study does that
really change my behavior or what if I
see somebody that looks just like me and
has the exact same issues to me and does
this you're just as likely to do that as
you are from a study so what's going to
actually change people's behavior and I
think you know having all these things
together helps but you can't discount
you know I mean how many things have you
done because somebody else did that I
mean know a lot of us we a lot of us do
that I mean it may not be scientific but
we at least are willing to entertain
that and that the good thing happens to
me too then I have a little bit more uh
you know that that thing becomes a
little bit more accurate yeah
um one of the things that I see a lot of
guys uh as they get older start talking
about
um testosterone various hormones uh
different deficiencies that aren't
necessarily just tied to their diet uh
it would make sense I think just
anecdotally as you get older things
change you don't have as much uh
testosterone or whatever how do you
think about diet as a way to to
supplement that right and kind of combat
what I think most people just say hey
like that's what happens when you get
older well I mean and there is this sort
of belief and I was I was certainly in
that you know that camp you know 15
years ago you know like I said I will
you know I will just say I was a
religious zealot anti-drug guy as an
athlete when I was powerlifting I always
used to yell at the guys who were taking
drugs I thought they were cheating I was
all always anti this I never personally
never did I still don't do that I don't
take testosterone there's a lot of men
on testosterone there's a lot of men in
their 20s and 30s now which is really
kind of shocking to me I think for most
of them it is a consequence of poor
lifestyle choices and this becomes a
metabolic Band-Aid you know the
testosterone industry is like a three
billion dollar industry right now that
is basically you're putting Band-Aids on
people and if you were too legitimately
really really clean up the diet and
lifestyle and get good sleep most of us
want to do that because a lot of hard
work it's easier to take a pill this is
this is a society we're in so I think
it's it's a it's a for many men it is
beneficial I see a lot of guys on
testosterone I saw as a doctor a lot of
guys on testosterone they're still fat
they're still out of shape they're still
miserable I'm like the testosterone's
not doing anything for you because in a
lot of cases it gets converted to
estrogen anyway because you just kind of
maintain this horrible environment I uh
you know I you know we've seen that
overall men's testosterone drone has
declined pretty dramatically over the
last you know four or five decades you
know and I think that's just as much has
to do with you know our diet our
environment in general and so I don't
think that decline is enabled I don't
even think age-related decline is
necessarily you know an an inevitability
you know for most men up to a certain
point maybe at 90 or 75 but I think 30
40 56 you should be able to maintain
high levels of testosterone function and
I want to be specific about that
testosterone function is what does
testosterone do for me maintains lean
mass keeps my fat Mass down uh sexual
function libido cognitive so those
things should continue to work well now
there is a concept of testosterone
resistance there's a receptor dyslexic
just like there's an insulin receptor
there's an insulin molecule there's a
testosterone molecule and there's an
androgen receptor and we know that the
receptor sensitivity modulates how much
testosterone we need so as long as your
testosterone was within normal range
and your function is good then you
should be fine you shouldn't need to
supplement that a lot of people will go
in there and say well you know I'm 40
let me get my testosterone checked and
some people will actually you know I'll
tell you how to lower it natural how do
you how to trick your doctor into you
come in there with a low testosterone so
you can get the script so you can sit
there no way yeah yeah of course yeah of
course they do
yeah so they they will artificially dry
their testosterone down so they'll get a
prescription so they can just sit there
and you know shoot up and you know get
stronger because I've seen guys on
testosterone and they're just beasts in
the gym I mean they're like you know I
mean literally I mean testosterone is a
steroid just like any other steroid
hormone and so they'll use it just so
they can you know maybe boost their ego
or something like that whereas uh it's
not a legitimate
um health issue for the most people I
think most people don't have primary
hypogonadism I think they have you know
secondary low testosterone second to
pre-diabetes obesity crappy lifestyle
and again if you'd address this thing
because you think about it why would you
want to take an injection or whatever
whatever form you're going to get it
when you don't need it you know I think
most of us would rather not need it but
again that requires getting good sleep
eating well training you know most
people don't want to do that
unfortunately what are some of the other
things that you think people maybe are
are looking at as Band-Aids they don't
realize they're Band-Aids and just they
clean up the diet so like all of this
kind of external
supplementation protein powders all that
obviously the testosterone are there
anything else that kind of just jump off
I mean most most of our modern medicines
I mean almost every medication out there
is a Band-Aid I mean you know I'm amazed
to see you know like I said our company
is focusing initially at autoimmune
diseases and I was just you know looking
the other day I was an ad for a multiple
sclerosis drug which I've seen by the
way multiple sclerosis improved
medically on this diet it's two
injections a year each injection costs
sixteen thousand dollars so thirty three
thousand dollars a year for these
injectables uh you look at things like
Humira and all these other stellar and
all these you know also kaleidos drugs
rheumatoid arthritis you're looking at
people paying you know upwards of fifty
thousand sixty thousand hundred thousand
dollars a year for these medications
which are simply Band-Aids all they do
is blunt the immune response so that you
have a Tamp down immune system you're
more susceptible to infection more
susceptible to cancer just so you can
mitigate some of these uh disease
symptoms uh those are all Band-Aids you
know what I did as an orthopedic surgeon
was putting mayonnaise up I could
replace somebody's knee but I didn't
really take the arthritis out of their
body I mean I you know this is the thing
that used to really I changed my
perspectives I would go in and
technically I'd do a really nice knee
replacement for some and they would feel
better the knee would feel better it was
it was crooked not straight they can
walk better their quality of life
improved and that knee they'd come back
to me a year later with their other knee
like hey Doc my other needs ready for
one too when we're going to do this one
and they had dread because they know the
surgeries you know it's a tough surgery
and they got to get through it and I was
thinking I was you know patting myself
on the back good job Dr Baker you this
person likes you because you did such a
good job with this first knee really
what I was doing was letting that person
down because had I known hey you can
probably avoid ever needing another knee
surgery if you just do these things with
your lifestyle and your diet I didn't
know I didn't know I didn't know to do
that back then yeah one of the things we
haven't talked about is caffeine you
mentioned earlier that you drink water
pretty much maybe a little bit of less
dry you drink caffeine I don't I just
don't like coffee this is kind of funny
when I was 14 years old my first Like
official job I worked as a dishwasher I
had to come to the Hilton Hotel clean
and Dish had to be there like four
o'clock in the morning to mop the floors
and he was a 14 year old kid getting in
at four o'clock in the morning is you
know it's kind of tough as a teenager so
I'm in there and I roll in there and I'm
looking like crap I'm just tired you
know it might have been a weekend or
something like that and the cook goes
hey kid here have some of this and he
hands me this cup of coffee I think it
was straight black and I think it was a
day old I think I'm not mistaken I'd
drink it like oh my God this is like the
worst stuff in the world so it put me
off coffee uh I dated a gal for a while
she was a school teacher up in up in
Wyoming and when I lived up there and
she was into the flavor cup I tried one
I was like
I just never liked this stuff I like the
smell of it I just I just don't like
stupid for me for whatever reason and so
I'm one of these weirdos that doesn't
drink coffee so 11 12 years old I think
that I like took a cup from one of my
parents and it was steaming hot black
coffee and I tried to drink it because I
saw them drinking it and I burnt my
tongue and everything like holy [ __ ] so
I didn't drink coffee till I was like 27
28 uh but then I started to drink a lot
of coffee right right and uh I thought
about getting off maybe maybe not
whatever and then I read studies to say
caffeine's good for you
is it is it actually good for you is it
not good for you like well I think about
the health impact yeah I mean here's
this is a problem with nutrition or
research in general you can find studies
it's good for you studies are bad for
you what what the hell is the difference
I'm not orthopedic surgeon here who's
gonna tell me the answer obviously well
right no I mean I think and this has
been my experience because this is this
is a very common question there's a lot
of coffee drinkers out there and a lot
of people try this diet and they ask me
about coffee and I said I wouldn't give
it up initially to start with you know
because you got all these changes with
dropping carbohydrates you're dropping
fiber out of your diet and increasing
your protein there's a lot of stress on
the body to initially do that and then
to go through caffeine withdrawal at the
same time is not a good thing so what
happens is most people they'll
transition to the diet they'll do it for
three or four months and then they'll
say hey I'm going to try giving up
caffeine now interestingly this is
interesting because there's a new drug
on the market it's called a glp-1
Agonist and so this is a glucone like
peptide in creating hormone which we
talked about earlier that people are
taking this medication was initially
prescribed for diabetes and they're
losing a lot a lot of weight which is
great and they're you know it's a drug
and of course the pharmaceutical
companies are going to make millions of
dollars and they're all happy about that
but one of the side effects a lot of
Physicians have been perform reporting
is a lot of people are noticing that
they're suddenly losing cravings for
things like alcohol coffee you know drug
addiction so it may have a rule there I
see the exact same thing with a diet
that we see here is that people
suddenly lose years to drink alcohol
suddenly they lose their urge to smoke
cigarettes or to abuse whatever drugs
they're on so or drink coffee in many
cases so there's something going on
physiologically that commonly that
affects the brain I'm sure but as far as
you know my experience has been about 50
of the people that quit coffee notice a
definite health benefit the other 50 no
difference at all so it's like yeah
maybe it helps maybe it's not I mean
caffeine if we look at technically what
why do why do plants make caffeine why
does a coffee plant make caffeine it is
a neurotoxin for insects that's exactly
what it's designed for it's just to
dissuade whatever things eat their
leaves grasshoppers or caterpillars or
ants when they congest that it literally
is a neurotoxin so they die so that's
what caffeine's function is now what
does it do to humans obviously it's a
stimulant obviously it impacts our
appetite in a way
um you know it can it can block mineral
absorption so there's pros and cons to
it so it's kind of one of those things
where you know if you're not drinking
you know if you're drinking six cups a
day then there's a problem you're one or
two in the morning for most people it's
not that big of a deal it's not a big
deal last thing I want to talk to you
about is Bitcoin there's a uh a
crossover between your uh meat and
Bitcoin and uh uh I would have said if
it wasn't so informed that it was the
meat people who found Bitcoin I think in
some ways uh the Bitcoin people found
meat it seems like like I see people
coming to bitcoin they all of a sudden
start eating more meat
um take away all the memes all the the
craziness and the fun stuff uh what do
you think is it about these two
communities that kind of come together
and maybe talk a little bit about your
interest or non-interest in Bitcoin yeah
yeah so I am a Bitcoin hodler just uh
just for for reference and the guys that
got me in a safe thing you know safety
and who wrote Bitcoin standard and a guy
named Mike Goldstein who I don't know if
you know either of those guys but uh
they're obviously big in the Bitcoin
community and they are both carnivores
and they've been doing it for longer
than I have I think both of them have
been doing it probably a year or two
longer than me
um I think that you know I'll be
obviously when we talk about
a lot of people in crypto I know the
Bitcoin guys will be mad to say Bitcoin
is crypto it's different right that's
that's the thing and I know we just had
that was the SBF guy and the FTX blow up
he was vegan by the way which I think is
supposedly I've almost was willing to
bet that you were going to bring that up
well I think you should it's appropriate
so anyway you can't trust I don't trust
people that don't eat meat I'll just put
it that way but anyway
um so I think that with regard to why do
we have this crossover I mean a lot of
us you know we sort of been jaded about
what we've been told about the system
you know it's like you know we don't
necessarily trust the people telling us
what to eat we don't trust some of these
major health care entities you know some
people don't trust the central banks you
know you get the same sort of level of
mistrust so there's that just general
willingness to to to to take The Road
Less travel I think that's where a lot
of the relationship is and you know I
know we talk about Fiat food and Fiat
money and there's there's a
commonalities there but I think
um I know I know with the with the FTX
collapse a lot of people talking about
self-custing everybody's pulling
everything off to exchanges now because
I don't trust you know what's going on
there if they even have what they say
they have they're like are they are they
holding only five percent of what they
think they have and you're gonna lose
out so I think I think the concept of
self-custody of your health is important
too because you know if you if you
Outsource your health to you even your
physician I can tell you as a physician
not to be callous or anything most
Physicians don't really care that much I
mean they don't have the skin in the
game that you do personally and yeah
they can be a consultant but they're not
going to lose sleep at night because
your elbow hurts I mean you know it's
it's just it doesn't impact you that way
so you have to really
um you know make it your mission to take
care of yourself and you can't Outsource
it to someone else I like the idea of
self-custody of your assets self-custody
of your health
um but also you're mentioning basically
like a first principles approach or like
a willingness and a courage to think for
yourself when it comes to your health
um talk a little bit the Bitcoin
Community obviously gets immense
pushback from the Legacy Finance people
the mainstream media uh their mothers
and fathers and cousins and people who
just think they're crazy or whatever
Health also like I'm sure you get tons
of pushback I see them tweeting at you
right
um how do you one deal with it but also
too like are there arguments that the
critics have that you're like you know
this would be the best argument that the
critic has against an all-beat diet or
something like that
well I mean it's funny I mean I've
watched it evolved over the years you
know the initial argument was you're
gonna die I mean clearly you're just
gonna die I mean you're going to scurvy
within three months you're gonna drop
down your teeth are gonna fall out so
that doesn't happen so then it becomes
well uh it's you know you're not gonna
die but you're gonna you're gonna
develop some sort of health issue within
three years so that doesn't happen then
it's like well
some people may get healthier with this
but but it's not sustainable and you're
like well there's people doing this for
25 years okay well so they just keep the
the the the counter argument keeps
getting reduced in significance and so
you know the longer you exist the longer
you sort of you know walk the walk it's
harder to contest that and that's what
we're seeing you know this is one of
those things that we're like I guess
with Bitcoin it's how many times it was
supposed to be dead right it's been all
it's been going supposed to be dead
since 2013. every year is going to die
and then it keeps going keeps going
keeps going so again no one knows what's
going to happen in the long term I don't
I mean I don't know if I'm going to stay
on this diet for 20 years I'm just
saying I'm gonna I'm gonna live every
day day by day
you know make adjustments as I need to
and so far I haven't had to I've had to
just you know continue doing what I'm
doing which makes it quite easy
um well I changed your mind like what
would be something that you'd say hey I
would reconsider uh yeah if I if I saw
my health significantly faltering yeah I
think that's I think that's a reasonable
approach you know
you know when I talk to some vegans
about this I say look what would happen
if uh
you know your health significant was
compromised would you would you eat meat
if you had to and the answer usually for
them most time they refuse to answer the
question so that would never happen I
said well I see it happen every day
quite honestly I I literally take care
of ex-feagans all the time
um so I don't you know like I said I I'm
not crazy to the point where I'm on a I
have a death wish or anything like I
don't want to have heart disease I don't
have cancer I want to have a good
quality in life so if I see that where
I'm convinced that that what I'm doing
is significantly harming myself I'll be
happy to switch
we've talked a lot about steak and and
uh meat chicken fish other things you
mentioned a couple times but just uh
Before I Let You Go like how do you view
the balance between steak versus these
other um well steak's the best no um I
mean I mean you think about it well you
know I wanted just you know if you were
to sit down and have a ribeye steak here
and a grilled chicken breast and a piece
of salmon right here
90 times nine times 99 times out of 100
I'm gonna pick the steak and I mean it's
because it tastes better I want it it's
just really satisfying but if you think
about just from again we'll go back to
we talked about our ancient our ancestor
people I know it's kind of a goofy topic
but when we looked at how we acquired
calories you know and what the
technology they had they they clearly
you know
before a hundred thousand years ago
before ranged weapons came into
technology around 80 000 years ago the
bow and arrow and the atlantal that
occurred as as sort of these Mega fall
animals died off but prior to that I
mean you had a spear that's what you
have to hunt for your food now if you
can take down a big elephant with a
spear which they clearly could
versus a chicken right how much effort
is it going to get to be to get a
million calories worth of chicken versus
versus a mammoth you can kill them you
can track a man with kill it in two or
three hours I mean this is routinely
what we see even today in Africa when
they kill kill office doesn't take long
so you've got that option so you get
this big giant hunk of ruminant meat
that has you know an elephant probably
provides six million calories and then
you've got a chicken where you're going
to get you know a few thousand calories
how many chickens are you going to chase
with your spirit so I think we I think
that's what we're hardwired to do I mean
most of us you know if we're honest
about it are going to say that steak was
much more satisfying to me than that
chicken a little piece of chicken so I
mean I still eat those things
occasionally but I just don't you know
again I eat what I like and what I what
I feel like eating so it's you know nine
times out of ten it's just like I want a
steak
um my last question for you is if
somebody wants to kind of go down this
path and and do some personal
experimentation uh what is your
suggestion as to how they get started is
it'll really go to the grocery store buy
some steak uh go home start eating and
like try not to eat other stuff or or is
there other well I mean I'll tell you
how I did it I mean I I lurked on social
media for about a year watching these
crazy freaking freak people eat nothing
but meat for a year ago and this is so
freaking stupid and crazy right I just
watched them and then I kind of like you
know I was like well [ __ ] I'm gonna try
it and and so I did literally I did one
meal I had steak and eggs for one meal
and I was like hey that was pretty good
I enjoyed I didn't miss the potatoes or
the toast or anything like that so then
I did a day and then I did two days and
I did three days and a week and then two
weeks and then back in 2016. I did a
full month of it and I was like [ __ ]
this is the best I felt in 20 years and
so that's how I progressed to this now
again like I said if you've got a lot of
health issues and you're on medications
you're probably going to need some
assistance you know we've we've got like
at carnivore.d diet which is our website
where we have a lot of people we can
translate we've got the communities and
coaching and all that stuff so that's
one way to do it but I mean in general
just you know start with it start with a
meal find something like you gotta you
gotta enjoy what you do don't just sit
there and eat plain ground beef you know
they just stare at that and go God I
gotta eat this for the rest of my life
that's not the right way to do it just
find something you like make it exciting
I think I'll say what I think I should
comment on this because there's a lot of
people out there within this Carnival
space you know they're you know these
guys are eating raw testicles and all
this stuff and you look at that stuff
and you're like that's gross I don't
want to do that and you that's not
necessary I don't care how much Primal
ancestor crap that's not what the data
shows data shows you can do finding each
state might sell steak and eggs all you
got to do you'll be healthy you'll lose
weight you'll feel better you don't need
to be eating raw brains and monkey
penises and you know you know
I just got to ask you talking about
testicles and raw brains and ancestral
uh primals uh liver cancer right right
what's your take well I mean he's doing
a good job of marketing himself I mean
it's a lot of marketing obviously and
he's you know obviously he's conflicted
he's selling a line of liver supplements
which again I think are unnecessary I
think they're overpriced I don't think
you need to do those things
um but I mean you can't you know I mean
you've got credit I mean he's he's
obviously putting himself out there and
he's impacting a lot of people probably
quite positively so I'll give him I'll
you know take my hand off him for that
um but again I don't think a lot of that
stuff is necessary that's not what the
data shows and you know like I said
you know if your goal is to cure
autoimmune disease or something like
that you don't need to do that you don't
you don't have to go to that extreme to
to uh to to do those things I think when
you make it
with that approach you turn a lot of
people off you know otherwise would
perhaps try it you can literally go to
uh Walmart and buy ground beef and
regular eggs and you can get really
healthy doing that I think most people
need to understand that if you want to
do all this other stuff and get Goofy
and put yourself on Instagram eating you
know pounds of Raw Liver every week
that's fine it's fun but it's
unnecessary
stunning your balls and eating eating
the liver is unnecessary all right uh
where can we send people to find you on
the internet uh both on Twitter and then
uh I think you've got a couple episodes
yeah so Twitter is actually nice now
that we don't get so much censorship
there so S Baker MD on on Twitter uh on
Instagram which I'm still being Shadow
Man on I'm so pissed because I made fun
of the world economic Forum so they're
Shadow Banning me about that which is
stupid it probably deserves it they do
they do so Sean baker1967 Instagram and
then Sean Baker MD YouTube and also God
forbid Tick Tock which is you know are
you on I'm on but you know kind of I'm
not putting a big effort in there yet
maybe later all right awesome and then
uh carnivore dot diet
is a good place or rivero.com so
carnivore not died if you just want to
do the diet you don't need any actual
medical care from a physician we'll
start accepting patients at rivero.com
probably this spring which we should
have a physician's license in all 50
states by the spring and then then if
you need help if you need someone to
help you taper down medications or
change medications that's where you'll
go okay how do you spell that
r-e-v-e-r-o Rivero okay awesome so
rivero.com yeah awesome well listen
thank you so much for doing this I
learned a lot and I think a lot of other
people will as well we'll definitely do
it again Future Sounds good awesome